[Music]
gee thanks every so often there's a
perfect stop a game releases which is
somehow brand spanking new and
ultra-modern but simultaneously historic
and nostalgia filled in 2019 that game
is Resident Evil 2 remake whether you
are skeptical of remade titles or you
are unbelievably hyped for the incoming
zombie apocalypse here's 21 things you
should know about the Resident Evil 2
remake
here's a quick overview Resident Evil 2
is set shortly after a zombie virus was
unleashed on the world in the mountains
above the city gradually the infection
made it into the city and now everyone
is dead apart from a very small
percentage of inhabitants re2 is a
survival horror game set in third-person
and is not for the faint-hearted jump
scares blood and guts tense moments are
ingrained in the entire outing and
there's simply not enough bullets to
kill everything we face survival horror
games are known for their difficulty so
here's something to take to heart
Resident Evil 2 remake uses adaptive
difficulty so what the hell does that
actually mean if you've played Resident
Evil 4 you've already experienced it
depending on how well or in my case how
utterly badly I did the game will
analyze your performance and adapt to
the difficulty to suit if you're an
unstoppable juggernaut expects more
fights with aggressive enemies if you're
getting your ass handed to you the game
will ease off to prevent your
experiences from being ruined there are
two playable characters to choose from
at the outset of re - Clare and Leon
Clare is a college student arriving in
Raccoon City to look for her brother
Chris Redfield the same chap who first
encountered the zombie virus in Resident
Evil 1 and also the guy who really
enjoys children's playgrounds in
Resident Evil 6
don't judge him also note that Claire is
a biker chick with a love of
harley-davidson motorcycles Claire knows
how to handle herself as her
military-trained brother Chris made sure
she knew how to take down Andrew Lee
guys on college campus and use a firearm
if the need arises on the flip side of
that we have Leon Kennedy a rookie cop
literally on his first day in the
Raccoon City Police Department so if you
see a birthday party in the game it's
likely his welcoming committee who
didn't have such a great day Leon is in
his early 20s and although he's a
firearms expert he's inexperienced as a
cop and tries a little too hard to get
everything done by the book there has to
be someone here there's a reoccurring
stumbling block with remade games why
the heck would we buy a game we've
already experienced what to put those
thoughts at ease everything in re2 has
been updated and although areas will
feel the same and invoke the same sense
of nostalgia everything will be unique
similar locations and story beats but
nothing will be the same so if you
finish the original back in 1998 you
won't know what to expect well well not
completely anyway the major plot points
and enemies will return just not exactly
how you'd expect them to ultimately what
I'm saying is do you need to have played
the original heck
new mechanics have brought this game
from 1998 kicking and screaming into
2019 here's five of them knives and
other weapons picked up will
automatically be used when grabbed by a
zombie or other beast this is taken from
the og Resident Evil remake these are
defensive weapons designed to keep the
action flowing and to give you a
fighting chance and they look damn
cinematic and badass - back in 1998 a
piece of cabling allowed Leon o'clair to
use security shutters in a single
corridor to keep that safe from the
invading undead this was a great
inclusion as we were forced to decide
which hallway was the best strategy
fast forward 21 years and this function
returns but with a significant overhaul
the fortification system allows our
heroes to collect stacks of wooden
boards which do exactly that board up
windows to make corridors a little safer
sadly though unlike 1998 the zombie
hordes will eventually break through
again so it's more of a rest bite than a
permanent safety zone improvement in
combats have been implemented also we
are told each enemy type has a weakness
to take advantage of for example the
lickers those ones that look like
inside-out clicky buggers are in fact
blind if you have the cojones it's
possible to creep past unharmed but is
such a huge risk and is so tense doing
so in addition we have the choice to
incapacitate enemies rather than wasting
bullets killing them like blowing off
the limbs of a zombie the great thing is
he'll remain on the ground for the
entire game revisit him 6 hours later
and the little ankle-biter
is still there waiting to tear your
Achilles apart another issue which
caused a great deal of frustration in
the 90s was inventory management our
characters have concealed fanny packs
with limits on how much you can shove in
there you're not a traditional English
speaker check the comments I'm sure
someone will explain that vulgar joke to
you anyway where where was I
to combat these issues our helpful map
will add an icon to any item we've left
behind the days of memorizing locations
have gone huzzah weapons and gadgets
have been slightly adapted to with the
most apparent this one the
electromagnetic field visualizer I'm
just gonna call it an x-ray girl it's
alright this item is completely new and
is used to see through walls to find
electrical components this will be our
break from shooting zombies to include
an additional level of puzzle solving
I'm sure you've noticed that that lady
isn't Claire she's ADA one of the
secondary characters in the game when
playing as Leon ADA will be around to
accompany you and occasionally we'll
fill those stilettos and become the
femme fatale ADA one to those that don't
know the re series Ada Wong is a
cornerstone but I don't want to talk
about her anymore because her plot
twists to new players is worth
protecting
Claire's secondary character is sherry
Birkin the daughter of umbrella
scientists William and Annette it's
uncertain we'll play as her at this
moment in time but I'll bet my hat we
will her diminutive size is perfect for
fitting into small gaps accessing areas
unavailable to Claire sherry is also
central to the plot but again let's not
spoil things
so he briefly talks about returning
locations having a slight overhaul to be
modernized in addition to this our
entire brand spanking new areas nobody
has experienced before one such location
is the orphanage we know nothing about
it at the moment but it proves that
Raccoon City is indeed larger than we
remember it
in 1998 Resident Evil to use fixed
camera angles to move around the world
causing great frustration when firing
blindly out of picture in this updated
version Resident Evil uses the tried and
tested over-the-shoulder third-person
perspective as introduced in re 4 and
perfected in re 6 gone are those fixed
camera angles some veterans will be a
little upset to see this modernization
and to those I remind them of the hidden
feature in re 5 lost nightmares DLC
which allowed those fixed camera angles
to be unlocked let's quickly address an
issue with early Resident Evil games the
English voice acting and direction it's
a bit bad so but it's good in fact sorry
but it looks like your party has been
cancelled what happened this was due to
a language barrier in the 1990s as the
Japanese developed game hired English
voice actors but didn't have the means
to understand if their performance was
up to scratch or the translation was
right for a Western audience thankfully
both the voice acting and the script
writing in the remake are simply sublime
heartfelt moments are believable the
horror no longer thrives on jump scares
although they are there with the
realistic character murmurings giving
authenticity to each scene Jesus
Resident Evil 2 remake is confirmed to
include extra game modes namely the
fourth survivor which puts us in the
shoes of hunk an umbrella special agent
the four survivor was sent into Raccoon
City to collect something integral to
the game's story essentially the four
survivor is a minigame set at a higher
difficulty and against the clock let's
say no more just in case new players are
listening on top of that is the tofu
survivor I never unlocked it back in
1998 but if I did it would have replaced
Punk with a giant block of tofu with
only a knife
conflict strange but true attire and
costumes have always been a part of
resident evil in fact many of Capcom's
games utilized changes of attire for
fans of the original both Leone and
Claire's classic costumes are available
and unlockable in-game for free I might
add but with different versions of Ahri
to remake comes other costumes the
deluxe edition gives Leon a Rick Grimes
inspired walking dead sheriff costume
and an evil within inspired noir suit
Claire also receives a noir variant and
military attire - but it's the Elle's of
Walker costume which will make Resident
Evil fans giddy with excitement here's a
quick history lesson
Elsa Walker was the intended lead female
character in Resident Evil 2 a
motorcycle racer as you can tell by her
leathers the game was eventually dropped
and development restarted as the re - we
know and love Elsa was changed to Claire
and linked to the first game via her
brother Chris the only comparison that
made it to the redesign was her love of
motorcycles in 2013 the cancelled game
was found and renamed Resident Evil 1.5
20 years passed and Capcom have finally
acknowledged the project in this costume
what a great touch we've already started
down the path of pre-order bonuses and
game edition so let's double down on
that now the standard edition of
Resident Evil 2 remake includes Chris
and Jill's weapons from the original
Resident Evil the sacred samurai edge
and also an exclusive theme if bought
digitally on console the deluxe edition
has all that plus Wesker's iconic
version of the samurai edge those
additional costumes we talked about and
the ability to play the game with the
original score definitely want to please
the millions of diehard fans get this
version physically and the cover art is
reversible there's also a steelbook
edition which includes that tells a
walker skin on top of that is the usual
collector's edition which has slight
differences depending on where you are
in the world all versions come with 10
inches of Leon what more could you want
the UK version comes with a set of keys
which are absent from the US version so
I advise double-checking what's
available in your locale oh and guess
what there's even a premium edition
which comes with a functioning keyboard
designed to look like the old in-game
save points ie those typewriters
complete with increments
if you're one of those people who like
4k gaming then be joyous it's here in
Resident Evil 2 remake both the ps4 Pro
and the Xbox one X will be able to take
advantage of this option but framerate
will be capped at 30 frames per second
personally the next option has me
excited again the pro and 1x will have
the option to play at 60 frames per
second at 1080 P framerate as smooth as
a baby's butt we're still left in the
dark about the framerate on the standard
ps4 and xboxone units so when does he
come out Resident Evil 2 remake releases
on January 25th on ps4 Xbox and PC are
you grabbing it I definitely am imma be
playing on release day on the channel if
you'd like to see some initial gameplay
come visit as I'm writing this the
Resident Evil 2 remake demo has finally
been announced running between January
the 11th and January 31st you can
download the one-shot demo in this
demonstration you will be tasked with
surviving 30 minutes in Raccoon City
you'll be able to restart but the moment
your 30 minutes elapsed the demo ends
and a final trailer for the game is
revealed you literally only get one shot
at this demo 30 minutes and it's gone
forever those 30 minutes will help you
decide if the re to remake is your kind
of game before I sign off I wanted to
bring one last thing to your attention
let me explain one of the most
impressive elements introduced in re 2
was the zapping system the game was
essentially broken into two playthroughs
one from Leon's perspective and one from
Claire what 1998 re 2 did so well was
half the first playthrough effect the
second weapons picked up by say Leon
would not be available to Claire during
her run if a boss somehow managed to
survive an encounter with one
protagonist they'd return in the second
playthrough as we could choose either
character to begin with there was
essentially four playthroughs of
Resident Evil 2 to experience before
we've seen everything at the time that
was mind blowing and added so much
replayability to an already fantastic
game this time around from the outset
Capcom told us the zapping system is not
in the game but recent evidence says
otherwise
with articles in official PlayStation
Magazine alluding to the zapping system
returning could it be on the way back I
can't say for certain but Capcom have a
history of redirecting our expectations
before Resident Evil 7 drops we were
promised no returning characters only
for Chris Redfield to suddenly show up
unexpectedly on road fuel we shall wait
and see on January 25th right thanks for
your time I appreciate it if you are
still here tell me who would win in a
fight between Chris Jill Claire Leon and
ADA
my money's on ADA I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
you